some of the most interesting aspects of
the cosmos including incredible
coincidences within our very own solar
system are completely left out of all
academic teachings and are virtually
unknown to the masses in fact there is
significant reason to suggest that
ancient human civilization were aware of
these cosmic coincidences as I'll be
discussing in this video let me start by
discussing Ceres and a few other
fascinating topics to help me connect
the dots for you as they build upon the
argument that ancient civilization was
aware of key details of the cosmos and
our own solar system we've all seen the
famous white spots discovered on the
surface of Ceres in 2015 if you're not
familiar Ceres is the largest object in
the asteroid belt which of course is
located between Mars and Jupiter I think
we all remember when the story first
broke a few years ago with the initial
photos coming back creating tremendous
shock among scientists and this story
made headlines throughout the world I
remember seeing the first photos and how
so many people thought wait a second are
those lights what is that this of course
became the subject of discussion and
debate among the conspiracy community
with people suggesting that it's an
alien base but as more pictures came in
over the next few days we got a much
better look at it and scientists have
theorized that it could be anything from
volcanic activity geysers ice salt or
even diamond deposits to make a long
story short
scientists believe that these spots are
sodium carbonate which is a type of salt
leading scientists to believe that Ceres
may have had an ocean which of course
raises many questions like I mentioned
Ceres is in the main asteroid belt and
of course we have two asteroid belts and
the other is the Kuiper belt located in
the outer solar system which extends
from the orbit of Neptune to
approximately 50 astronomical units from
the Sun the Kuiper belt is actually much
larger and contains much more mass than
the main asteroid belt located between
Mars and Jupiter now I for one do not
agree with the leading mainstream
explanation for how the asteroid belts
were formed which is that during the
initial formation of the solar system a
tenth planet tried to form between Mars
and Jupiter but due to the strong
gravitational forces of Jupiter it was
unable to form into a
in it I think it's far more likely that
what we're looking at is a destroyed
planet or moon of some kind
I also think that this is what turned
Mars into what it is today we know that
Mars once had massive lakes rivers and
oceans but something happened and we
don't know what but I like many others
suspect that life once existed on Mars
but I also think that this events
whatever it was may have happened far
more recently than billions of years ago
and I've discussed in multiple other
videos on how Mars somehow retained
water channels rivers and lake beds
despite nearly four billion years
according to NASA of wind and sand
erosion and although Mars atmosphere is
far less dense than that of Earth's NASA
scientists have stated that dust and
sand particles still travel up to 70
miles an hour and take that into account
with Mars you know having global
sandstorms which have been known to last
longer than three months on end and
consume the entire planet continuously
what also must be mentioned is that Mars
has literally millions of dust devils
every single day so yeah I think there's
more to this story and I find it
interesting that NASA has contradicted
themselves numerous times involving the
erosion on Mars it just doesn't seem to
make sense that water channels and
rivers that existed nearly four billion
years ago would survive well four
billion years of dust devils and global
sandstorms and a minimum would be
covered up or the sides would be eroded
and I've discussed these details in
other videos but back to the asteroid
fields and how they were made some will
say that the entire mass of the asteroid
belt is not enough to be that of a
planet or a moon but really nobody could
say that with any type of certainty
considering that well they don't have
prior knowledge of how big these objects
would have been Northerly know how fast
or from what direction or angle the
impacts would have happened
obviously the forces of a collision
would be mind-boggling and most of the
debris would be blasted out in almost
every direction into the universe but
only a small amount would be retained in
orbit and that's why I suspect that the
Kuiper belt is the remains of that
collision which were not able to escape
the gravitational influence of the Sun
ultimately nobody knows how these belts
were created but there is newfound
evidence too
support my claim that it was a planetary
collision you may have seen headlines
from about a week ago discussing how a
meteorite was discovered with nano
diamonds inside of it far larger and
more complex and ever found before due
to their chemistry and leading
scientists are suggesting that this is
leftovers from a tenth planet that once
existed in the solar system and was
destroyed approximately four and a half
billion years ago now let's be clear
nobody can say what was going on in this
solar system even a million years ago
much less four and a half billion years
ago and I'm not suggesting that the
solar system isn't billions of years in
age I'm simply pointing this out because
it's an example of the typical arrogance
that exists too often in the scientific
community and has existed throughout
history but here's the thing they're
saying that this meteor with the nano
diamonds must have moved into the
asteroid belt after the collision so
wait a second why are scientists so
committed to excluding likely
possibility that the asteroid belt was
formed from a destroyed planetoid of
some kind this is not to say that no
scientists have discussed the
possibility but it is without a doubt
considered a fringe of possibility and
this is something I've researched quite
a bit and it's honestly a bit disturbing
how many scientists completely scoff at
this possibility yet the most recent
scientific evidence actually supports
the theory of a planetary collision
forming the asteroid belt but for some
reason most of the articles on this
newly found meteorite mentioned
absolutely nothing about the asteroid
belt whatsoever and I actually had to go
searching to find an example of it which
I found here in the New York Times
article by the way if there indeed was
some sort of planetary or moon collision
which created the asteroid belts and if
it happened far more recently perhaps
tens of thousands of years ago this
would explain various myths and legends
of the war in the heavens as well as
cataclysmic events that have happened
here on earth so the next thing I want
to discuss is Mars's moon Phobos and
there is an incredible anomaly on this
moon which seldom gets any attention
from the scientific or academic
community since its discovery there is a
monolith which scientists say must be a
boulder which is massive in fact it's 90
meters in height
nearly 300 feet tall and it is somehow
standing straight up how and what made
that happen for something so long and
narrow to be completely upright is
incredible but it's even more
fascinating when you take what Buzz
Aldrin said about it on live TV a few
years ago something that the mainstream
news networks have completely ignored
and he stated there's a monolith on
Mars's moon a very unusual structure and
when people find out about that they're
going to say who put that there
I mean whether you believe he went to
the moon or not the very fact that Buzz
Aldrin said this should raise some
eyebrows and pair it with the fact that
this unusual anomaly is not taught in
schools and most of the public are
completely unaware of it I mean I find
that interesting I mean if they did
think it's just a boulder I think it
would be getting a lot more attention I
mean if something like this existed here
on earth which it doesn't I mean we've
never seen any type of Boulder of that
size or shape standing straight up like
that not even close but if there was it
would be a freakin tourist attraction I
mean can you imagine now I don't know
what it is I'm not suggesting that it's
an ancient obelisk like others have or
that it's evidence that ancient humans
are originally from Mars although I
think that anything's possible what I do
know is that I'm curious I want to know
what it is and I want my taxpayer money
to be spent on taking better photos of
it so we can figure out what it is I
mean really this is the best photo we
can get some grainy blurred photo the
next thing I want to discuss is Saturn
particularly the amazing and absolutely
massive hexagon shaped storm which is
located at the North Pole
look at this thing isn't the shape of it
unbelievable let me first mention though
that hexagon shapes are found naturally
in nature and a few examples include the
Giant's Causeway in Ireland which was
created from volcanic activity we even
find hexagons that make up the honeycomb
within beehives even the spots on
giraffes are hexagons in shape we even
see flies and various insects who which
eyes are made up of hundreds of hexagons
too and when I said that this storm is
massive each of its sides exceeds the
diameter of the earth by 700 miles and
you can see a comparison of it here in
this photo
in fact this storm is 20,000 miles
across or more than 32,000 kilometers
across and has sustained winds of
more than 200 miles an hour or 320
kilometers an hour but what makes it
even more intriguing is the fact that it
changes colors and you can see two
separate examples of this between well
two separate space missions including
the Cassini mission where this was
documented changing from a blue to a
golden color in just a few years but
speaking of changing colors I have to
discuss the false color images that are
widely used by NASA and because of that
the mainstream media as well as
academics and these photos are were seen
by most of the public false color images
are literally artist renditions and
although impressive and beautiful they
are not at all what it actually looks
like and I find this to be detrimental
false color imagery spreads ignorance
and misinformation because not everybody
knows that these are false common colors
I mean you watching this video might
know this and know how to read the fine
print and understand it but you'd be
surprised and how many people are
unaware of this and I encourage you to
talk to children and people in school
and ask them about this stuff and you'll
be surprised and how many of them were
taught or shown these photos but the
teachers failed to mention that oh yeah
some artists added these colors to them
in fact here's an example of a NASA
photo of Ceres which of course has false
coloring and you'll find this picture
right on the nasa.gov website I would
say a prime example of this though is
the Eagle Nebula which is also known as
the pillars of creation and the famous
Eagle Nebula just well it doesn't look
like this and this is not to say that
it's not spectacular and if we could
travel closer to it and see it with our
own eyes I'm sure our jaws would
absolutely drop in amazement another
example is the famous Hubble telescope
photo of ten thousand galaxies which
we've all seen this brilliantly colored
photo but unfortunately all we truly see
is black space and white light take the
ax drama to galaxy which is the closest
to the Milky Way galaxy and this NASA
photo is enhanced in so many ways from
the color certain aspects of its shape
to the very fact that the picture would
make you think that we can zoom in and
get a really good look at it which we
can't and here you can see actual
examples of what these are what this
galaxy looks like through telescopes
here on earth clearly MA
different than the NASA photos released
to the public and this leads me to the
topic of black holes well you know when
you see pictures like this you have to
know that it's a complete illustration
because we literally have zero photos of
any kind which documents a black hole
and most people are not aware of this
because well we've never actually seen a
black hole and we've only been able to
infer their presence but scientists are
expecting that this year 2018 will be
the year that we get our very first
image of a black hole so that is
exciting now I want to jump into the
most interesting of all the information
which involves these cosmic coincidences
that apparently ancient human
civilization was aware of which is
completely unexplainable based on
everything we thought we knew or were
taught are still being taught about
ancient history in school in Prior
videos I have mentioned Randall Carlson
and how he details the specific
dimensions of the Great Pyramid of Giza
Egypt and how it computes to a ratio of
43,202 that of planet Earth and the data
suggests that whoever constructed the
pyramid literally knew the dimensions of
earth what we need to look at then is
the specific number 4 3 2 and how it's
been used by multiple ancient
civilizations from around the world
including the total years of the Kali
Yuga which is a 432 thousand year period
also the total years of the Sumerian
Kings list which just so happens to be
the same number 432 thousand years this
number also just so happens to be the
radius of the Sun 432 thousand miles
so it gets interesting when you consider
that half the diameter of the Sun is
four hundred thirty two thousand miles
but half the seconds in a day on earth
is 43 thousand two hundred again you see
that four three two number and obviously
the zeroes are excluded in the study of
numerology but the examples get more
crazy the moon for example is four
hundred times smaller than the Sun but
it also just so happens to be four
hundred times closer which is why we get
total solar eclipses oh and by the way
these slides are from Randall Carlson
which is how I learned of this
information and I highly recommend that
you check out his YouTube channel and
his website and his works on cosmic
patterns and cycles of catastrophe which
will blow your mind and I'll include
links in the description of this video
but definitely subscribe to this guy in
support
definitely go check out his channel but
this leads me into the number 108 and if
you divide the average distance of the
Sun or moon and divide them by their own
diameter you get the same exact number
108 and we can all thank this perfect
ratio for the abundance of life here on
earth this perfect relationship between
the Earth Moon and Sun has fostered the
ocean tides to allow life to thrive here
on this planet now this look at the many
other examples of the number 108 and
just like we looked at the radius of the
Sun if you look at the radius of the
Moon we also see the numerological
number 108 being the 1080 miles making
up the moon's radius but this is where
we see it used abundantly the number 108
in ancient cultures civilizations and
religions from across multiple
continents from around the world 108 is
significant in the Hindu religion with
108 tantra x' and 108 is also the total
number of Upanishads and 108 just so
happens to be the amount of beads that
are in the mala in Hinduism yoga and
Tibetan Buddhism which by the way yoga
dates back 6,000 years and possibly as
long ago as 10,000 years and that's just
what we are aware of and there's also
this example of the 108 towers in Bekaa
in Cambodia which I mean why did they
choose this specific number even Homer
of the ancient Greeks who famously
authored the Iliad use the number 108 in
his book The Odyssey with 108 suitors we
also see the number 108 in ancient China
with the 108 stars of Destiny from the
famous water margin so why did so many
ancient cultures use the number 108 it's
so specific I mean it's not like it's a
round number like 100 which we could all
wrap our minds around they worshipped
this number and it just so happens to be
the number that represents the ratio
involving the earth the moon and the Sun
that has allowed life to thrive here on
planet earth don't you find that
interesting because it is unexplainable
why this 108 108 number is so
significant and used so often and just
like the analogy I use in my last video
the telephone game when information is
passed down over time and through
translation information gets lost but at
the foundation of any myth or legend
there is some truth to it in this
number 108 or 4 3 2 is something that I
believe was retained but somehow known
by the ancients another example of this
and I don't think it's an accident or a
coincidence at all but the shape of the
building that arguably controls so much
of the world today is a Pentagon and
what are the inside angles of a Pentagon
well you guessed its 108 and they say
that they chose the Pentagon shape
because of how it fits between the roads
around it but ok I don't buy it no other
building on earth is of this shape and
they could have shaped it a million
different ways to fit in between these
roads I do believe or I should say that
I know that there is without a doubt
powers-that-be that exists a network of
people that essentially well-controlled
the world basically a group of leaders
that make up various people within
governments intelligence agencies the
news media the entertainment industry
the scientific community etc and some
people call them the Illuminati but calm
whatever you want without a doubt there
is a network of people that essentially
control different sectors of around the
world and these people I believe have
more information about certain things
than the general public and one example
of this is ancient history
this used the TV show Lost as an example
you either loved it or hated it I loved
it you can laugh if you want but all
that aside this show is absolutely
loaded with occult symbolism and I love
how the show symbolized the nature of
reality and our existence life and death
and how we are a product of our
experiences and many other things
including some things about the ancients
and one thing that stands out is the
unexplained reason why the show creators
chose to use the number 108 throughout
the series and I mean dozens of times
often very discreetly and unnoticeable
to most of the audience for example
there are 108 minutes to reset the hatch
clock to save the world from the
electromagnetic disaster and the
passcode itself to reset that clock
which by the way is also the same exact
numbers that Hurley used to win the
lottery in the show and all those
numbers just so happened to add up to
108 obviously well not a coincidence
because once you hear just how many
other examples this 108 is used in this
show the number 108 showed up on various
clocks throughout the show even when
Jack went to the lighthouse he had to
the wheel to 108 degrees another example
is when doggin was often seen holding a
baseball which involved the scene
discussing it and baseballs just so
happened to have 108 stitches and I
would say that this is just a
coincidence if it wasn't for the fact
that the same guy's hourglass was timed
to 108 minutes even when Jack was doing
surgery on Ben the ECG briefly showed
108 heartbeats none of this is an
accident when creating a TV show or a
movie
everything is directed and orchestrated
every frame has intention and I'm
telling you dozens of examples in this
show most of which were quick and
unnoticeable but other examples include
the 108 whine cases at the monastery
Desmond was at another significant
example is that it was 108 days between
the crafts of the plane flight 815 to
the rescue of the oceanic six and the
dates that they were rescued was January
8th which is one - Oh 8 108 and there
are other examples of this - these are
just a few that I'm sharing but who was
this show created by well JJ Abrams who
I'm a fan of he's a great filmmaker and
it turns out he also produced a
television show called Fringe which I've
never seen I'm not familiar with it but
while researching this topic it turns
out that a character named Morgan on the
show was passenger number 108 on a
flight during some episode and I've been
unable to find an explanation as to why
JJ Abrams likes to quietly throw in this
number to so many Havas works I mean I
don't know maybe he sits at the cool
kids table among various insiders who
knows I mean I think we all agree that
we live in an age where there's a war on
information and there is without a doubt
and if you've seen my other videos there
is without a doubt significant evidence
that proves that the true history of
ancient human civilization was far older
and far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school or their teaching in
school today
and there is without a doubt people
within the mainstream academic and
scientific community trying to suppress
this information and a prime example of
this involves a legitimate cover-up
involving the Great Sphinx of Giza Egypt
and tunnels and chambers that exist
inside and underneath it and you have to
ask yourself why the authorities have
released literally zero photos or
videos of any kind of what's inside
these tunnels where they go in the
chambers that are that they lead to and
I highly recommend that you watch my
video on this days you'll see that the
suppression of information is real and
if that's not enough for you look at how
the same network of insiders are
attempting to prevent the expiration of
the newly discovered pyramid void a
massive chamber found or discovered
hidden inside the Great Pyramid of Giza
like what does that tell you so if
you're new to this channel or the topic
of ancient human civilization take it
upon yourself to research it further
because you will have your mind blown
and all the information and data that
exists that you were never shown about
in school and are somehow left out of
mainstream documentaries but the word is
getting out and people are becoming
aware of this information and it's not
an accident that the topic of lost
ancient human civilization has
skyrocketed in just the last few years
the mainstream establishment narrative
is crumbling and the question becomes
what is it that they don't want the
general public to know about ancient
human civilization why are the most
amazing details excluded from academic
teachings altogether definitely leave a
comment to share your thoughts on this
topic but I'm gonna close it up there
hit the like button and subscribe if
you're new to this channel but I have
many more videos to come on a whole wide
variety of topics I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight take care everybody